rien n'arrête christopher maublanc
malvoyants le loir-et-chérien s'était
lancé il ya quelques mois le défi de
conduire une voiture de rallye nouvel
exploit ce week end mais cette fois dans
les airs aux commandes d'un avion
objectif casser les codes sur le
handicap et tenir son pari fait à ses
enfants le reportage d'audrey champigny
à l'aéroport de blois le breuil
il ya bien un pilote dont cet avion aux
colombes christoper mal voyant de
naissance il est accompagné d'un
instructeur pour pouvoir manoeuvrer ce
robin aircraft entre sécurité ne fait
pas le bonheur
le plus fou c'est qu'il s'agit de son
baptême de l'air en effet christopher
n'avait jamais pris l'avion avant et
pour cause il en a une peur panique
alors quelques minutes avant le
décollage pierre son copilote lui
explique les bases si vous tient loin
vers l'arrière vous avez frappé
l'empennage donc là on va monter exact
après le brief la pratique là on va
tirer ou pousser sur le manche pour
monter ou descendre de l'avion sur la
gauche et la droite pour refaire qui
votait l'avion sur son axe heures le vol
durera 30 minutes au dessus de blois
chambord cheverny vitesse de croisière
170 km/heure altitude 600 m à
l'atterrissage
l'émotion est palpable
quand on a quitté le sol
j'étais un peu je savais pas comment
réagir j'étais un peu perdu qu'un jeu
mon corps je n'arrivais plus trop à
gérer qu'au bout de trois minutes je me
suis concentré sur mes objectifs mais
j'ai réussi à apprécier ce moment des
fois de moi même je disais infos que je
vire un peu à droite md oui c'est ça
donc parce que j'avais senti l'avion
basculer un peu à gauche c'est tellement
décuplée que c'est le moindre mouvement
tu as l'impression que
que tu perds tout les repères sous les
yeux de ses enfants christopher a réussi
son pari celui qu'il leur avait fait
piloter un avion un super papa